lucy powell matt hancock says he's sorry
he's let people down and he's gone
shouldn't that be the end of it
well i'm afraid this goes to the
judgment and the leadership of the prime
minister as well because
matt hancock yes it's good that he's now
gone but he should have gone
on friday and the prime minister should
have sacked him
and these are the difficult decisions of
leadership and
i'm afraid it feels to me like the prime
minister has a very
dangerous blind spot when it comes to
issues of integrity
and conduct in public life and that's a
really big problem
and it's even bigger problem when you're
in the middle of a pandemic and you're
asking the public to also have integrity
and conduct in the way that they
go about with their own lives
are you going to oppose the
severance uh payment that mr to which mr
hancock
is uh statutorily entitled i think it
comes out at something like 18 000
pounds
well i think most of your viewers would
be appalled to think
that um there's going to be a severance
payment to
matt hancock in this circumstance let's
not forget
he as the health secretary was the guy
who recommended that our nhs workers
after the year that they've just had
in this pandemic on the front line who
have worked flat out who are now on
their knees
he recommended that they in effect had a
pay cut
and i think to find out that he's now
going to get
thousands of pounds as some kind of
severance redundancy payment
for frankly uh being caught on the job
while he was on the job
you know i think would be pretty
disgusting to most people
and we will certainly be calling that
out and asking the prime minister
not to give him that well we don't know
whether
mr hancock wants to claim it or not so
to be fair
um it's at the moment hypothetical but
to get an idea of how far you want to
press this
when professor neil ferguson
conducted an extramarital affair mr
hancock
was one of his most vociferous critics
and actually he said
that he supported the call for a police
inquiry
um do you think that the police should
look into mr hancock's
uh behavior
sorry i couldn't hear that very well
could you just say that again there's
something about
this of course yeah of course i'm trying
to work out how far labour wants to push
this
when neil ferguson uh ran into
trouble uh mr hancock supported a call
for a police inquiry and i'm just
wondering whether labour
would do the same in this situation
well my colleague fleur anderson has
referred this to
the police because she wants to know we
want to know
whether the police will be looking at
whether matt hancock did
break the law in um in his actions
at the time you'll remember when this
video was was taken we were all told
that we could only have close contact
with those that we were in a bubble with
they were our bubble
and that was the only people we could
have close contact with that was the law
at the time
yet it now turns out that matt hancock
was actually in two bubbles at the same
time
unbeknown to other people in that bubble
and that is how
infection spreads so yes there are
serious issues here which need further
investigation and we will be
uh looking at those because of course
you know matt hancock was the first to
say that
neil ferguson and others should have
resigned when they broke the rules and
that other people
needed to abide by them so you can't
have the rule maker
also being the rule breaker people want
to know there's accountability in that
the government obviously wants to limit
this to an issue of one individual's
conduct
but i think from what labour leaders
have been saying
you think that this is endemic in
government and i just want to
pick up on a couple of the points that
you've made you've said that um
mrs collidangelo is an old university
friend of
mr hancock's appointed as a
non-executive
at uh the department of health um
but of course that the point was cleared
by the
uh permanent secretary department of
health um
why go after them on that basis
well look i think there are widespread
there seem to be widespread issues here
as i say the prime minister seems to
have a really dangerous
blind spot when it comes to to these
issues we now
also find out that matt hancock was
using his own
private gmail account to
undertake effectively negotiations and
discussions
about very large nhs contracts
that comes on top of other questions
relating to michael gove pretty patel
and others about the the handing out of
government contracts and so
yes there are some very serious issues
here that seem to cut across
the whole of government about how
government contracts
uh government pay paid for jobs are
being handed out and whether they're
being done
in accordance with those nolan
principles of public life and in
accordance with
the ministerial code of conduct which
i'm afraid the prime minister seems to
uh you know disregard whenever it suits
him it's not really worth the paper it's
written on at the moment
and so yes we will be pursuing those
wider issues and there are there are
those wider issues across government
it is of course the role of the
opposition to point out the government's
failings to scrutinize it to point out
the issues of cronyism chamocracy all
that kind of thing
but um what would you do
to change that i mean presumably if
you're making the case that this is
characteristic of the whole government
and
not joff just a couple of one-off
problems
there is something systemic that has to
be tackled here so
what is that and what would labor
actually do about it
well i think it does speak to who does
the conservative party
represent here in whose interests are
they governing
are they governing in the interests of a
lot of their
wealthy donors their mates in in
business looking to
to make a fast book off the the public
sector or are they governing
in the interests of ordinary working
people who are trying to get by in this
country who need decent pay
decent housing and decent jobs and
it feels to me time and time again that
this conservative party i'm afraid
are governing in the interests of their
wealthy
friends and that's when it gets found
out so
yes it's it's not just about your
processes and whether you've got strong
leadership
and you know i absolutely believe that
kierstarma would have
sacked matt hancock or or if it had been
any one of us in this situation
on the spot and how you deal with them
but it's also about
in whose interests are you governing in
whose interests
are you a politician and that's where
the labour party and the conservative
party
you really have quite a big uh
difference i think
you say the cursed armor would have done
this differently and been decisive and
all that
but look you're confronted with the
government against whom you
can and have made over many months
credible charges of hypocrisy
sleaze cronyism and sheer incompetence
yet you managed to lose a by-election in
a previously
safe seat last month you're in danger of
losing
another one this week and you're way
behind in the polls how can that
possibly be i mean how do you manage
that
well the by-election on thursday has not
happened yet
uh we've got a fantastic local candidate
in kim ledbetter who is a very
passionate local community activist
she's not really a
politician at all and will be fighting
for every vote on
on thursday so let's see what happens uh
there but of course you know in
in a pandemic it's not a time of
politics
as usual people want to see the
government succeed
we want to get back to life as normal
and
we have to take a a slightly different
approach as
as the opposition people don't want to
just hear from
us in terms of opposition for
opposition's sake they want to see us
being
constructive and and working uh where we
need to working with the government to
end this pandemic so we can all move on
and we're emerging out of that i
hope uh soon and um you know i think
you'll hear a lot more from labour over
the coming
months about how we'll deal with some of
those underlying issues that this
pandemic has exposed you know the gross
inequality in this country and health in
wealth and in our public services
one very one very quick last question if
i may um
sunday time this morning says that some
labour figures are trying to persuade
tony blair to stand for parliament again
might there be some labor hearts going
pitter-patter at the
prospect of the return of the old boss
uh i don't think so no um we've got a
very
uh good leader in case dahmer and we are
all
united uh behind him you know we've got
that
t-shirt we've watched that movie before
where we turn in ours on ourselves and
and focus on on these these other issues
and that movie doesn't
end well for labour so we are focused on
being united
and getting behind uh kirst armour so
that we can put forward that
compelling radical big offer to the
country
that we need to do at the next election